well fact Checkers have been busy having
a little bit of a field day with
President Biden State of the Union
Address the commander-in-chief accused
of exaggerating his record and making
some key contradictions like these
here at home inflation is coming down
here at home gas prices are down a
dollar fifty from their Peak
food inflation is coming down not fast
enough but coming down inflation has
fallen every month for the last six
months or take-home pay has gone up
the president getting knocked for all of
those claims Biden also got a real-time
fact check over this attack
so my many some of my Republican friends
want to take the economy hostage
Republicans want Medicare and Social
Security Sunset I'm not saying it's a
majority
[Music]
let me give you anybody who doubts it
contact my office I'm not politely not
naming them but it's being proposed by
some of you
look folks
your ideas that we're not going to be
we're not going to be moved into being
threatened to default on the debt if we
don't respond then Biden drawing some
laughs for the wrong reason when talking
about getting tough with oil companies
I said we're going to need oil for at
least another decade
and that's going to exceed
and beyond that
we're going to need it
and despite getting called out on the
falsehood some Democrats and the media
giving the president's speech a very
glowing review
I think this was the best speech I have
ever heard him deliver it was fun and he
seemed to be getting a lot of fun out of
people heckling him and and the feedback
that he was getting you actually felt
like the union is strong it was
delivered with a lot of energy and a lot
of pace he was a little Rowdy right he
was a little fun he was engaged in
enjoying the exchange it felt like the
British Parliament didn't you think he
was sort of Mr Smooth we were all
thrilled last night wasn't the president
just great what I loved about the speech
it was true Joe Biden I thought it was
so masterful I didn't hype Squad like
that Jesse what did you think yeah uh it
sounded like an ultra Maga speech to me
and he plagiarized the entire Trump
platform if the guy had had blonde hair
in a tan I thought Trump would have
still been president if you listen to it
the core message was that we've shipped
all of these jobs and factories overseas
and I'm going to be the one bringing him
back well he doesn't say anything about
that he was vice president and Senator
whether he's shipping the jobs over
there but that's fine and then he says
I'm going to get tough with big Tech and
I'm going to get tough with big Pharma
and we're going to crack down on
fentanyl pouring over the Border okay
okay
we've been saying that for a long time
Joe then he said it's gonna get tough on
China
and this is a blue collar boom this is
literally exactly what Trump said during
his stay to the union
and then he even used the Forgotten man
analogy he said you know a lot of you
feel forgotten he's hollowed out old
construction sites and these poor Towns
come on
the best part was when he went full
populist and said he was going to get
rid of these junk fees these Resort fees
for places that aren't a resort or
airlines that treat your children like
baggage
and then he was going to lock up people
that stole coveted money well go over to
Chicago because they took the money and
gave each other bonuses
I'm not really upset with how people
were screaming and yelling like I'm not
a big decorum guy especially after the
fact that the last president they spied
on his campaign framed him to be a
traitor and then leaked his taxes so if
someone whoops and hollers and gets
boisterous no big deal
it wasn't well delivered he's a terrible
speaker but I did feel the unifying
message
America's great place optimistic I just
don't know if Joe is the guy to deliver
on all those messages that he played to
us okay and he also he this is the call
for that they wanted me to play
President Biden was reflecting on his
speech today listen here
many of you have seen we've had a spirit
of debate last night with my Republican
friend
my Republican friends
they seem shocked
when I raise the plans of some of their
members
and their caucus to cut Social Security
and Marjorie Taylor grid another stood
up and said Liar Liar
reminds me of a liar liar house on fire
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well first I just to comment on that on
that media Montage being a pet owner
they're like a pet owner whose dog you
know finally you know is potty trained
outside and I just said oh look what he
did oh he's such a good little boy
they're the the the expectations are so
low for Joe if he could just make it to
the podium without falling over or
shaking hands with an invisible Goblin
that's like a huge success and you could
just tell them that they were so happy
and so relieved I am I don't think it's
unreasonable at all to Heckle someone
who smears you and I think in this you
know this might have been a really
decent intervention for Joe because all
he does is smear people right he smeared
gun owners border agents uh with the
whip Trump voters uh the police you know
so somebody has to call him out and if
you're in a place where somebody's
actually saying it's like it's like
imagine a Republican president saying
you Democrats uh want to kill children
with the with a dangerous vaccine that's
the almost on the same extreme of saying
like we want to take money from the
elderly and let them die alone you know
in in poverty because that's what he's
saying so it's like of course you have
to stand up because it's about you and I
think that you know because these uh
these speeches are so fake it's so
artificial the one real thing is the
heckling it is it's an injection of
reality it's people at home going oh you
are full of crap that never happens so
you've got to have somebody that you
have to have I don't I'm not even think
to think about the content of the
heckling itself but that I do think you
know
you decorum is no you don't keep decorum
if somebody is smearing you you just go
right at it right don't you agree I know
Dana I I mean I'm a decorum person you
are you know but what if I smeared you
Dana well that's right
Dana doesn't eat salad with a fork that
wouldn't work that'd be the truth I mean
I think that that you make a good point
maybe that maybe you're at a point now
where
um the the country is saying we want to
have real-time reaction like we do on
this yes I think that this is this isn't
as long as as long as everyone's cool if
they're going both ways yes right
because that is now and if that's going
to be the way it's going to be I always
go these beaches are going to be really
long uh judge Janine what do you think
well when when he started with the
Forgotten man that's when I started
thinking about President Trump okay it
was like right from the beginning but
there's a couple of points that I want
to make number one
um when he criticized
um the Republicans and saying he started
by saying many and then he stopped
himself and he said some Republicans
want to stop social social security and
Medicare and they booed him now I got to
tell you something I am so sick and
tired of hearing the Democrats say it
I'm uh Kareem Jean-Pierre say it the
president's saying it one Republican
senator apparently said it and now
they're going to Broad brush everyone
and at that point I don't blame them
they had to take a position I don't like
that it wasn't as you know as as proper
as it might have been but at that point
there are so many people watching this
speech they needed to hear that they are
not in favor of this and stop
gaslighting a stop up lying now the
other thing that really made me crazy
was when Biden started talking about
Tyree Nichols and you know how sad and
how terrible that was and we all agree
with that but then he immediately went
into racism and the talk that you have
to have if you have a brown or a black
child I mean he just intertwined the two
the death of Tyree by five black police
officers and then he goes to racism and
the other thing that that when he
started talking about Big Oil and he
says how dear Big Oil make these profits
and use the record profit to buy back
their own stock rewarding the CEOs and
shareholders we are either a capitalist
country or we are not and for him to say
they shouldn't be doing that is
outrageous and he forgets that he came
into office saying I'm going to shut
down the fossil fuel industry I'm
canceling the pipeline I'm not going to
sign new drilling leases and they then
he says how dare you and by the way I
checked the prepared speech with the
actual speech he apparently unless I'm
wrong he didn't plan on saying we need
another decade at least a 10 more years
of gas and oil and beyond that he just
ad-libbed himself which was a good thing
so there are places where if you want to
talk bipartisanship hey let's talk about
it we're not cutting Social Security or
Medicare and you don't want to either we
need big oil and apparently you say you
want it for another 10 years and finally
fentanyl how dare you say that you're
response to fentanyl is to use more drug
detection machines you want to join with
the Congress you talk about China and
you talk about the Border when you talk
about fentanyl that's how you bring
America together
Harold do the Democrats feel pretty good
today what's what are you hearing from
all your sources well I think Democrats
do feel good first it's good to be back
it's good around the table as opposed on
the camera
um I think one of the things just just
reacting but Democrats feel good about
it and I think if you look at the
polling I think a majority of the
country feels good about it which leads
to this point you know the everyday
rhetoric of this President a good friend
of mine was telling me today and if you
look at every every president the last
four or five we had with the exception
of President Trump and this is a
compliment to president Trump their
everyday rhetoric was oftentimes a
little more pugnacious from the
standpoint that the media would
oftentimes splice and and dice a little
bit what they wanted us to hear them say
whereas president Trump would walk out
the White House and he would give that
press conference himself and he was
oftentimes very upbeat and very positive
people may reacted somebody was always
upbeat and positive this speech here is
really a time when everybody in the
country gets to see the president and he
normally whomever the president is he's
always cordial he's always conciliator
he always projects uh you unity and
projects that we have to find ways to
work together no president ever comes
before the country and says that the
union is in disarray I'm angry I'm mad
I'm going to continue to be that way no
they they come across because they come
across the way the president came across
last night they get a little partisan
but it's not totally that way so it's
good that people see him that way the
appropriation of some of these languages
remember let's make America great again
with President Reagan let's make America
great again and the Forgotten man is FDR
so I think it's a tradition I like the
fact that presidents build on that
tradition always ensuring that at the
core of this American experiment is to
ensure that the very least and last
regardless of race has an opportunity to
be pushed up so I was pleased to see to
hear pleased to hear the president say
that I shared last night what I was
looking for most and I shared it on the
show and I thought your comment your
answer last night Jesse too one to five
around China was right there should be
consequences I thought the president
would have taken the point a moment last
night to lay out a dividing Doctrine on
on China uh for a whole variety of
reasons the metaphor with the balloon
was obviously the pr what really
provoked that but I thought we missed an
opportunity there and I'm not one that
likes to pit Great American companies
oil companies and big Pharma we wouldn't
be where we are whatever you think about
vaccinations we wouldn't be where we are
without big Pharma and the speed in
which they develop these vaccines and
therapies and two I give Big Oil a lot
of credit whatever you want to say about
them should they pay more taxes should
we have a fair tax system sure but let's
stop with the US versus them thing
particularly when it comes to Great
American companies and great
manufacturers in this nation it is funny
because like he's basically saying you
could you should invest you got 10 more
years yeah 10 more 10 more years who
does that that's not a good investment
yes exactly unless we only have 10 more
years yes AOC said remember I wanna
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now